yutz excuses aux journées sur octobre
date dadiès catch donc le nouveau
octobre date qui vient de sortir
hier c'est parti on va pouvoir suivre la
nouvelle histoire de cet incroyable
poulpe assez son mariage soit que c'est
ça il est juste en retard il est
toujours en retard
bah oui mais qu'est ce qui doit être
qu'est ce qui l'aurait qu'est-ce qui le
retarde mais le lac sur son gros cauchy
s'est pas encore habillées fais-toi
présentable elle t'attend mais quand
même pas choqué parce que s'il ya un
pool que kim et de la laque sur son
cauchy d'un an juste parce qu'il n'est
pas habillé à mauvezin of control
octobre un arm savoie la hausse en
anglais mais étant donné que je suis
extrêmement fort en anglais je vais
pouvoir vous traduire aux houles à clé
parfait mais je pense que ce mec c'est
la définition même de cette chanson quoi
finalement
il peut se faire un câlin tout seul hop
boîte ça suffit goâve d'or
qu'est-ce qu'il a pris il a eu pour des
trucs random sorte de gros morceaux de
sucre y est up nickel at oui des ballons
j'aime les ballons ouais
et voici l'octopus dance bon à part ça
il faut que j'aille ou non aux ja j'ai
trouvé de partenaire elle doit tellement
qui fut ma partenaire actuellement je
suis bon bilan au le costume non pas de
sa crédibilité non pas sur le gap non là
qui seront testés à moi c'est faux je
sens le truc foire avec une peau de
banane
qu'est ce qu'il fait là
en mon dieu on a trouvé le dieu des
pieuvres nom se passe pas comme ça qu'on
se regarde dans le miroir octobre date
mais dont les va-t-en ville une pancarte
voilà thébaux oui je suis là voilà je
découvre la porte
excusez une blague assez bon au maire
d'och et faut pas que je sois suspicieux
mais je ne suis pas sûr puisque du to
reach of the rings merde
oh je suis juste sur un pied voilà ce
parce que je suis stressé voici l'anneau
m amano n'a jamais été aussi compliqué
et non
oui ça c'est pas un âne aux égarements
un bracelet qu'elle avait 9 à noah aux
is love va dans la cuisine très bien
mais avant tu me laisse regarder ma
famille je ne me dites pas que quand il
est devant ça il n'a pas l'impression
d'être un peu exclu à tétouan
[ __ ] je déteste ce sont gets the
kitchen ok elle est où les kitchen est
ce que cette porte là je ne pense pas et
regarde papa élevé oui c'est moi je suis
votre père oui ok faut que je fasse le
café mais non mais non pas la chaise pas
là je tiens voilà assis toi ma femme a
le bec son bras pas de délation lofo
faire du café thé elle veut que je lui
fasse du lait on est mort oh [ __ ] âgé
lui en mettre partout
merci c'est moi où en prenant la tête
j'ai tout renversé par terre à ça me
fait plaisir de vous faire des steaks
1-1 mes chers enfants le dernier il pas
sur le green valley state a en langage
des pieuvres ça veut dire tiens voici
pour toi aller ah pardon à il n'est pas
cuit au pardon oh [ __ ] je n'ai même
pas vu mais qu'est ce qu'il fait là est
il en train de mourir sur un banc alors
oui je garde
oui on va devoir couper des et que je
coupe on n'a jamais vu avec coupé de
bûcher avec autant de style coupé parce
qu'on fait le con et le style la leçon
de chose qui doit être là dedans à les
ouates attendait mais si les enfants qui
ont plus de ballons montcoy à leur ai
dit que j'allais faire sur mes enfants
sa valeur raser la moustache
allez allez honte honte ont
tranquillement ça c'est la chambre
doctorales en fait voilà bien dans des
ballons comme ça j'aime bien les fois ça
lui prend une forme qui arrime shake
c'est quoi cette famille je suis pas un
perchoir d'esclaves laissez moi jouer
avec ce ballon de basket m'ont fait ça
tu veux jouer au basket car veston tu
veux jouer au basket ou pas laisse ton
ça te dis merde au yes boîte mais qu'est
ce que je fais ce colloque c'est l'homme
à la toque de cinq mètres il est
complètement malade lui ont valu au
supermarché pour acheter des céréales
pour les enfants apparemment et pizzas
et sodas du chocolat thé et une bonne
trouvent les pizzas congelées ça marche
non marc moiroud chocolat et du chocolat
pour la paix une petite claque
voilà j'ai le droit de monter dans ton
caddie ou à la de l'avoir entre les
jambes comme ça je lui fais un show
aurait pour lui alors tu veux je fasse
at work faut que je lui vends désolé
madame je m'en fous c'est pour mon fils
ça les ors foirail
regardez où les sodas que je leur prouve
qu il tient truc je suis le roi les
supermarchés au tueur ait sa place là il
est trop bien caché je lancerai des deux
longs carton sur les gens comme un gros
bâtard comment j'ouvre ce truc au
perdent non non ça c'est dieu non je
suis une pizza mais non c'est bon tout
est normal
alors où sont les sushis à l'épreuve
sushi y ait au non non c'est pas moi
c'est pas moi cassez-vous les paquets
d'eau mais non mais non je suis bloqué
mais non mais non elle est fausse
on est passé on lui dit que sa manière
de danser et un peu bizarre est ce
qu'elle fait et d'incantations up
ah ah bah oui la pomme alpha de colmar
watts on a fait les cons se pose enfant
chéri c'est très simple tu peux venir à
l'aquarium avec ta famille hier où tu
peux rester à la maison tout seul
allez viens on papa qu'est ce que tu
attends
et à l'ère de tranquille fait le moment
présent quoi ré démis arctique est au
meilleur pardon et à la tête de tous me
regarder si vous me stresser jeu 40 là
que je m'en bats les steaks
tenez monsieur non j'allais voler la
caisse plus tard
pardon mais non mais je suis tout à fait
normal on dirait que cette peluche avait
tout le temps choqué dirait qu'elle a vu
tous les trucs du plus riche de la
planète à toi ou cantonade
c'est presque aussi bien que les autres
attendez moi ma famille s'il vous plaît
le faire charcuter taste buyster qu à
quoi ils descendent les escaliers liban
100 most ko
attends je veux rejouer vers l'avant
[ __ ] ah bon vous savez quoi je pense
qu à mon avis on peut faire un truc bien
mieux je trouve qu'on a tous rêvé de
faire ok faut que lui et ses prix allez
allez monte au début ce qui n'existe oui
où
qu'est-ce qu'on a gagné un poisson or
comme je suis content tiens j'ai un prix
pour toi mon amour
il est pour toi c'est parti 4 5 6 aux
[ __ ] plus personne ne peut l'arrêter
chez eux mêmes ceux d'à côté c'est quoi
ce délire là vous rigoler c'est parti je
vais pas wa tumba attendait mais mais
qui me l'a carrément pas foirer va pas
de pitié pour une pieuvre au bout du
projet écrit au ralenti la haie mais
[ __ ] mais le mec sain j'ai dit ah
voilà quand même à applaudissent et moi
ok le mec pleurs quoi [ __ ] c'est
d'avoir un sacré problème psychologique
tokyo
plus que trois pardon voilà moi je pars
en faisant du budget
le jeu qui est carrément de la triche
quand ils peuvent tuer tombera effectifs
et la longueur de la table ronde mais
non mais qu'est ce que c'est mais what
pourquoi elle me doit lancer plus haut
non mais [ __ ] mais vous êtes carrément
c'est pourquoi je suis seul pourquoi
personne ne m'aide
mais deux mois plus tôt il y avait comme
dans les douches avait un trou dans le
sol qui aspiraient tout le bas valais je
sais déjà fort de cette vidéo sur
octobre à j'espère que ça vous aura plu
en tout cas moi je me suis bien marré et
puis on se retrouve très bientôt pour la
suite et pour des vidéos sur d'autres
jeux
j'ai tout le monde puisse à bientôt bon
week end pis tu hésites ch quel thème
les beach debbiche
mais je comprends pas car c'est qu'on
était comme moi bien embêtant
agnel sacré dit samba jeune steve